hi I'm dove Cameron and this is the
wired autocomplete interview sitting at
home in her pajamas way more of a slob
than you thought she was who is deaf
Cameron I ask myself that every day
who does dove Cameron look like people
have often said that I look related to a
man deciphered and I can sort of see it
like in the sense that we are usually
both blonde with green eyes and I don't
know
big cheeks she's really beautiful also I
think the fact that I played Sophie in
Mamma Mia in a live production and she
played it in the movie probably an easy
go to who is dove Cameron Liv or Maddie
y'all I mean I've never tried to play
twins before it was complicated at first
like in the first season it was
complicated because we still had the
same amount of time as every other
sitcom like on the Disney lot we still
only we had three days or her sold two
days filming and we had to do everything
twice so that was a little crazy like
Disney was like you've three days to
film it's totally fine and then they
asked us to do it once in two days cuz
obviously it's like way less expensive
and then they're like oh so you can do
it do it like that forever
and it was so hard for like the first
season then we figured it out and then
it was like second nature yeah I'm gonna
be answering this question till I die
who is deaf Cameron related to do you
want to get all the time are you really
- Cameron Diaz and I'm like you do know
that there's a first name second name
thing happening there who does dove
Cameron play in Angry Birds I play Ella
the Dove I think she actually is it of
that was really cute of them I think
it's a very interesting game what was
dove Cameron's first acting job
she only actually answered I don't know
I mean like up for me a bunch of things
happened at once I didn't I didn't -
episode arc on shameless writer on the
site at the same time that I did The
Mentalist writer on the same time that I
did like Malibu Country so like all
these a bunch of guest stars when I
first started what is dump Cameron's
favorite Disney Princess I feel like my
favorite Disney Princess growing up with
probably Ariel I'll stick with that I
mean I think mal now after two sentence
three is considered a Disney princess so
that's pretty cute what is deaf
Cameron's favorite number why do you
guys care
about this I don't even know what that
is but Steph cameras Oh 11 probably 11
cuz one is that one with itself
what is deaf Cameron doing now talking
to you that's so funny that people would
Google that what does stuff Cameron
doing now like Google's gonna know what
what is dove Cameron like in real life
I hear she's really difficult to work
with oh oh no complicated what state
does dove Cameron live in I can almost
guarantee you anybody who you want to
know what state they live in is either
California or New York pretty much
guarantee you I mean not obviously not
not always but what is dump Cameron's
zodiac sign I'm a Capricorn do you know
what's super silly about me and the
zodiac sign is I don't really buy into
it that much but I have two zodiac
tattoos I don't know I feel like humans
are such a broad spectrum that we can
kind of find ourselves in every zodiac
sign but I will say I find a lot of the
same signs in my life which is why I'm
like oh that's weird all my best like my
women are all Aries and all of my super
compatible like soulmate people are all
tourists repetitive God be something to
it right what is dubbed Cameron's vocal
range how to draw deaf Cameron I can't
even draw anything more complex than a
stick figure in front of like a house
with a son like when people like draw
something that's what I draw or I draw
like the Superman s you know like when
you were in middle school and you're
like to the three lines and you're like
oh that's crazy turns into heads that's
what I can draw how does stuff Cameron
plaits he rolls you get a body double
who's like your height your general body
size and then we all wore wigs because
everybody's hair looks different even if
you have the same hair color your hair
texture and length and and then whenever
I was Maddie my body double Emmy would
play live and then when I was lived my
body double Shelby would play Maddie
whenever you see me on camera it's
always me it's never another girl but if
you see me hugging somebody that's a
body double it's a long story
camera trickery how old is dove Cameron
today 23 years eight months and six days
I just walk around knowing that just to
keep it in my head
how to get dove Cameron hair have many
many hours of professional work that I
have nothing to do with oh that's
intimidating oh they're all looked the
same but in there very many variables in
stuff camera a twin no is dove Cameron
perfect it's not even close is dove
Cameron British no that's these are so
interesting to me like I want to know
what prompts these questions cuz you
just walk around being like you're
stupid silly dorky self on a daily basis
like walking around like drinking coffee
and eating whatever you eat like protein
bars mostly and then like people are
like she'd like you don't think that
these people are thinking these things
about you is stuff cameron russian yeah
considering where my family is from a
lot of my family my bloodline comes from
russia and france so in that sense yeah
but also I think Hungarian I think those
are like my my three is dove Cameron on
Broadway not currently but I am at the
Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in Los Angeles
reprising my role of Claire Johnson in
the light in the Piazza is stuff Cameron
related to James Cameron can you imagine
this whole time I've been like she don't
say anything no I'm not related to James
Cameron that'd be amazing though anybody
who's related to James Cameron would
have like the craziest life I feel like
you'd go on many adventures if you were
related to James Cameron he's kind of
amazing is dove Cameron real what have
you just like went straight through my
skin yeah just she's been a hologram
this whole time does dove Cameron Oh
snowboarding cloud nine so here's the
deal with that I can snowboard but in
cloud nine because you're doing a movie
you can't get injured as an actor and so
they don't actually let you do any of
what you see on camera usually some
people do their own stunts but I am NOT
trained and so no I am NOT snowboarding
in cloud nine last little tidbit about
that we had seven different body doubles
on cloud nine and two of them were men
with a long fake blonde braids so shout
out to the many people who make it look
like I'm really good at snowboarding
done stuff camera know how to skateboard
that's the most left of the old question
I don't feel like I've ever even been
photographed on a skateboard I don't
even feel like I know anybody who has a
skateboard no I definitely don't know
how to skateboard does deaf Cameron have
tattoos I have nine tattoos as of today
my first tattoo was here it's a capital
one side on my hip my next tattoo I got
when I was 18 it's a Gemini sign on my
other hip it's exactly parallel my next
tattoo I got when I was 20 with Thomas
it's a Sun on the inside of my finger he
got a matching one the next one I got
with Kiersey Clemons she got the O on
her pinky so it's four and then I want
to say my next ones were five six on my
wrists and then I got the snake sorry
the snake and my ankle tattoo seven
eight like on the same day and then I
got this one nine a week or a week ago
maybe two weeks ago in London just on a
whim yeah I plan on getting many more
though they're so addictive when people
say they're addictive they are does dove
Cameron have tick tock I think I do I
think I do have a tick tock I think
it'll only be activated once I start
releasing my music but if you see like a
tick tock account that's very active
that's not me I think I have an account
but I don't know if anybody follows it
or anything it might be like private for
now does stuff oh there is a girl on
tick tock who looks crazy like me and
always goes on there and like sings my
songs it's really funny I don't know her
username I just kept tagged in videos a
bit on Twitter and it always makes me
laugh shout out to you you're so funny
does stuff camera need glasses so yeah
kind of so I don't normally but when I
get really tired like my eyes get really
tired if I've been traveling her I've
not been sleeping or I've been looking
at a lot of blue light they get like
weaker and so I'll put my glasses on
like if I'm really tired but I don't
need them all the time and I don't wear
contacts oh I thought we can dub Cameron
speak French she bought him food at home
so I could speak a little bit of French
I can speak more French I think than I
think I can cuz when I go to France
I understand almost all of it my
favorite word in French I feel like is
Pepe all which means butterfly or
abettor PE which means umbrella whenever
I say that I just think it's so cute
Pepe all cute will dove Cameron be in
riverdale season 4 so somebody made a
fake Riverdale trailer and used an
music video of mine and it is I finally
watch ticks I didn't understand why
everybody was asking me when I was gonna
appear in riverdale like it was this big
thing on Twitter I'd always get tweeted
about it it was like nice going on what
do people think I'm in riverdale
somebody made like this unbelievably
convincing trailer and used like the
shot of me that's never really used and
even I was like oh this looks so legit
so shout out to whoever made that
trailer because like I woulda bought it
no I'm not at Riverdale we'll have
Cameron get married
I don't know Google will will I ever get
married it's like a magic eight-ball
wheel to have Cameron get married house
dove Cameron won in the awards I won an
Emmy I don't I don't think I've won any
other awards I mean I was really honored
when I won the Emmy I was really floored
really surprised super felt like it
wasn't real so crazy to even say that I
never talked about it or think about it
yeah that's it I'm very very interested
behind some of the questions like some
of them I totally get and I get asked
them a lot in person anyway but some of
them I I'm very surprised right I look
at this and I'm like who is this enigma
you know I'm not nearly as interesting
as you think and I think that's a good
thing
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you wired this was very
interesting to me I love you all and see
you